a movie star you have another story for
me I do so he must have told you about
it I can at the beautiful red memory
bank - yeah I was really young and I was
I just started prostituting and I used
to dress to the nines faces anyway this
man picks me up and a little sports car
he's a big guy and he's a white guy and
we're driving and the next thing you
know I wake up I fall asleep so I was
younger I used to fall asleep all the
time because I'd be up for days I fell
asleep
luckily I wasn't talking to st. Peter
but that might have been better I set up
I didn't know where I was and I I see
this like French is like you know with
like a board and then to post and and I
look to my right and there's this metal
kind of a fence and there's cows and I'm
thinking like what and I always say like
I look a little closer and the man that
brought me there is out there with a
pair of boots on butt-naked up by this
cow and he's rubbing I guess it was it
was poop on him and he was jacking off
and I thought oh my god I'm killed by
this guy this guy here and look at a
person Big Joe jack about my cows oh no
I know
do you've any idea where you are I'm Cal
Cal Gary country or something um you
know big cheering women out take maybe a
Chino or sublease out that one that's a
one sided all right yeah oh yeah badly
I'd feisty for quite a while and and its
mother he just my you know I've survived
all these years time hurts daytime
nighttime I've survived all these years
because I'm pretty good with my you know
I'm not psychic but you know I I'm in
passing I can feel things and suddenly
told me get up and run you know
and I'm not a really kind of a paranoid
person or Frank but when I swim but my
body is running before my brain tells me
to do it you know I gotta go so I get up
and I start running down this it's like
a it's like a wall of I'm not not hey
but like straw and I don't know probably
fifteen feet high and it's just it's
like this road this and that yellow
brick road is yellow walled road down
the side and I start running down this
thing and and I don't think he's going
to be gone so I'm running I'm running
I'm running running and and all of a
sudden I see the car lights come down
the path so I was but I did I trip that
I fell and I didn't notice him I was
running because it was like an optical
illusion there's like a wall and then it
stops there's a gap and but there's
there's a strong behind it so it looks
like it's there but it's not it's like
kind of fell through and I was like yeah
then I guess he was a farm house with
lights on so I start running I'm ready
it's part of this whole compound survey
and I think obey the made it a whole
bunch of felt whole [ __ ] family
see weirdos you're like they're gonna
cut me up in here I mean mess me with my
teachers I don't know I like ozone ozone
can't do that and Sam tells me I see a
head of his defense to get out and it's
kind of big chain around with a lock on
it I'm like I can guess I have to give
Eckankar sure I went back I go oh I
don't know why was the first when I woke
up I didn't know where I was and so I
just I was scared I just took off
running I didn't with I know that I told
him this yeah I've gotta get back in the
car I go girl and this thing I was
scared well right so he gets back in the
car and he's looking at me he's kind of
like look at me up and down trying to
judge with what I'm thinking or whatever
so I said um I said sorry I fell asleep
I said you know we can go do what we
were gonna do if you want to go I'm
seeing like there's this man who's that
species Oliver loves me and he's no I
just have to go one place else before I
take you back and I'm thinking one more
place that's my text my coffin so we're
driving on this road and this is that
like side watching streetlights it's
just like Road and like little dirt
compliant little dirt and clang and
there's like agriculture and cows
wherever it's just and it's pitch-black
on I'll obviously I see a streetlight no
this is like a street light it's like to
be cables
hey you cross like this with the sting
hanging in the middle that's a stop
lights like two brothers are crosses but
I see a car coming our direction and so
we're getting closer we're getting close
I can't just scream you know so I just
grab a straight left right and just guys
I'm completely ready go not bad just we
hit him and so he could sound excited
cuz how the car he scream at him I
gather Christ are running I don't know
why I started running down this road I
gotta get away he might show this guy
and get me - I don't know but I'm gonna
take me on the factor so I'm running
down this road right and uh how fast are
you going everybody how fast were the
cars going it was just one car me and in
our car in his car oh I'd say probably
40 well I don't know I was even about
speed it's just stop and have something
else as a witness over there you know I
always try to kill the guy I just wanted
somebody else there so I could take off
running he was a big guy this other guy
was revealed you anything so I took up
running in and I ran I run around and
around and I strike said the headlights
coming so I ran off the road in the head
and it was another quite wasn't here so
I kept walking in the Sun side you come
up now you're gonna set it up with dirt
road gravel you knew dirt and smells
like I could kick the cow urine was like
knife you know like potato and so I I'm
dressed to the nines I am dressed I am
dressed I could go anywhere right now I
mean I go to the cabbie Wars I think I
hate to go anywhere they say why I'm
lucky got this road and what am I gonna
do I got I don't mean many anything
which is your ring I'm wearing I'm
wearing stilettos
oh Jesus I would but Becky knows if I
can run trackers to those you know so I
like so Chuck starts going by who these
pickups with these but these these
farmers whoever they're screaming at me
whoo whoo whoo suffice I could get some
ice highway right here now when I was
like like 19 20 years old I was like Bam
Bam Bam Bam everything this is but
sitting up here you know say everything
was just so I just kind of deal with my
little help and they pulled over now I
never just never have before ever did
before and they probably never will ever
again turn to dates like this but they
just pull the pickup truck over now
there's nowhere to hide
it's just like filled with fifth growing
and more fearless and
stretch with nothing around nothing
nothing the high by and they just open
up the pickup truck to us go in the
middle and I turn dates I do the whole
truck I didn't care and so I did shoot
trucks like that I say today I had a
couple of hours on me I'm now but now
but do I spend this money to get home I
mean there sis I'm still walking with
nothing around right and so obviously
this early Corvette Pulis passed me he
turns around he comes a brand new
Corvette clothes everything's done
you're doing out here I said trying to
get out of here and he says what do you
need to go I said Los Angeles and he
says oh okay
and so he says I'll take you to the bus
station and I said where you going
he says the courthouse I said you a
police code I'm not a police attorney
goes no I'm I'm an honorable Oh your
honor it's a judge so he takes me he
doesn't date me he takes me to the
Greyhound station he gives me a ticket
and he gives me $200 and he doesn't get
out of here this is not the place for
you
I said thank you very much you know and
so I get on the bus I got back there
with like 470 bucks I close for the look
like like manure yeah you thought I was
so lucky
no no I think I could've just woken up
talking to st. Peter I was like you know
I woke up at all yeah you know but I
remember looking over here this man I
like it anyways Texas Chainsaw Massacre
I thought I could think of was take the
states are better this guy that says
you've had more than your share of these
kind of run-ins I don't I don't know per
se now I have that many of them because
it's because I go with my I'm empathic
and I do realize this so I go with my sd
if7 says there's 24 hours before getting
somebody's car if my signet says don't
do it 24 hours has to pass before I
might be wrong but I might be right who
knows I don't give you I knew I
shouldn't it so much anymore because I
listened to my get you know it's just
that's just getting your life so long
isn't it seven tell you I'll get Ricardo
see these buttons I'll go this bends are
really and I'll just keep like flexing
on these buttons or something I'll go
ice my mystique I just don't know I
don't know they try to tell me something
but I don't know how to read it so I
just know I need to take out the car and
they'll say oh no I saw
come back in 24 hours you know then
we'll be judge this whole situation by
yeah I've allowed myself 24 hours has
passed I can't get talked to they're
gonna tell you serial killers and Shiro
sure rapists they are charming they're
charming and they well captain a they
have a good personality and they look
nice to smell nice they don't look like
the troll under the bridge or you
wouldn't get into the bar all right we
thank you so much for sharing this
another story what did you history one
day I don't have any stories like that
you know some simple matter sorry I just
forget everybody yeah I see with you
some hypnosis looking mark on hypnosis
they can be on the mark show thank you
you